floo being the antidote to the human
condom and then us being able to achieve
it in whatever way we find we're clever
more clever beings right we can start
figuring out like what works like well
works for each of us individually
what works for our children bertha in
the world we give them a lotta different
options and they figure themselves for
sure if our educational systems like
we're built around what gives flow
through our students i'm sure that
learning and accelerate tremendously
well gives rob our students robinson
tacks about talks about that yeah well I
went to a Montessori School for for
elementary school and those schools tend
to build a curriculum around the kids
predisposition and interests what do you
think about this glowing homeschooling
unschooling I don't know unschooling
away from the K through 12 system kid
having a just a computer when they're
young teach themselves language teach
themselves math or science or history or
our to create whatever they want to
explore and teach themselves without any
guide with maybe some sort of mentorship
or guidance as well as interesting but
what about the social part and then the
social part as well as very important to
some some kids also don't have an
interest as much in the social part and
they want to just we had the resources
to build a curriculum per kid you know a
unique educational profile per student
that would be awesome for sure I support
that aren't they doing something really
interesting in Finland have you heard of
this what is it in Finland the
educational system now I read is being
built not around subjects but around
problems to be solved and problems
companies projects require knowledge in
several different subjects to solve the
problem and so the students end up
learning you know about math they're
about science about environmental
studies whatever to solve the problem
we'll take the project basis but from
like elementary school that's great and
they're not showing the sort of the
highest levels of success in their
educational system yeah they're very
sophisticated